Hollywood has an embarrassingly poor
track record when it comes to adapting
anime properties for the silver screen
and if the negative reaction to ghost in
the shell' is anything to go by that's
not likely to change anytime soon
Hollywood hasn't abandoned their
attempts to find the right approach to
anime remakes but some of the stuff is
just too weird for Western sensibilities
Prison School on the surface Prison
school seems like the kind of property
that might fit right in with other
dystopian teen flicks but the way this
anime shows its young characters
struggling against injustice is nothing
like The Hunger Games this adaptation of
Akira hero motos manga series follows
five boys who get accepted into a
prestigious school that was formerly
only available to female students after
almost immediately getting caught
peeping in the girls locker room
the boys are thrown in the school's own
horrific prison what happens is way too
graphic to describe here but it's safe
to say that Hollywood isn't likely to
consider buying the rights to a show
that blends high school life with Fifty
Shades of Grey any time soon
no game no life the overwhelming
popularity of sword art online has not
only been responsible for a boom in
MMORPG themed anime but also paved the
way for advances in real life virtual
reality gaming but while a live-action
series of sword art is currently being
developed for US television that isn't
likely to happen with another series
called no game no life this anime is the
story of Sora and his little sister
Shiro to reclusive gamers who are
transported to a world called dis board
by the God of gaming after they defeat
him in a game of chess once there the
siblings launched a plan to use serve
the reigning God and take over the story
in itself is pretty standard in the
emerging MMORPG genre though the
extremely creepy relationship between
Sora and his eleven-year-old little
sister raises numerous red flags that's
all we can really say about that but
it's pretty safe to assume that you'll
never see no game no life on the big
screen in the US and you may be put on a
list even if you watch the anime seco
boys recently named among the best idol
anime of all time by my anime list
Sekou boys is also one of the most
bizarre idler otherwise the show follows
the exploits of Mickey a recent graduate
who lands a dream job managing an
all-new idol group which isn't that
unusual except this Idol group is made
up of four greco-roman busts yeah
singing stone busts st. G or geo Medici
Hermes and Mars take the Idol world by
storm with Mickey's help which mainly
involves wheeling them from gig to gig
in a wheelbarrow the offbeat humor and
crazy setup that made this unique show
so popular would undoubtedly be lost in
the transition to the big screen elfin
lead originally airing in 2004 elfin
lead came to the attention of western
audiences after the success of stranger
things just like the duffer brothers hit
elfin lead follows a girl with
mysterious powers she escapes
experimentation at a government facility
and wreaks havoc on her captors the
sibling creators of stranger things were
quick to acknowledge the show as an
influence once people started noting the
similarities even still there's too much
violence for Lucy story to make it to
the screen intact and there's one
terrible instance of animal abuse that
would be enough to give Hollywood execs
nightmares
it makes the subsequent brutal murder of
her tormentors satisfying to watch but
animal lovers beware kinnikuman
first conceived by the writer and artist
team known as boiled egg kinnikuman
initially started out as a parody of 60s
sci-fi series ultraman but was also
largely influenced by the rise in
popularity of pro wrestling in Japan the
story follows the missing Prince of
Planet Kimiko as he attempts to prove
himself worthy of his title through
wrestling competitions with other
supermen all of whom are embodiments of
the places they represent even though
branded action figures flooded American
toy stores back in the 80s one of the
reasons the anime never really made it
to the US is because of the character
Brock and man a full-fledged Nazi who
had wrestled in an SS themed outfit the
fact that they attempted to make his son
Brock and jr. a good Nazi was even worse
in many ways despite its cult status in
Japan
Kimmy : is way off the hollywood radar
Mysterious Girlfriend x
equal parts engrossing and just plain
gross Mysterious Girlfriend
X is the unconventional love story of
sixteen-year-old Akira and his loner
classmate Makoto two teens who bond over
spit yep
realistic or not Hollywood execs aren't
about to get excited over a love affair
based on a saliva fetish no matter how
well-received it's been in Japan plus
you'd be hard-pressed to find a pair of
actors willing to spit in each other's
mouths that hasn't stopped anime fans
from wanting to see more animated
weirdness however only a single season
exists right now despite plenty of
unused material from the original manga
a petition was started to bring
Mysterious Girlfriend
ex back those studio hoods Entertainment
has yet to oblige a kick on translating
to English as empty can the utterly
bizarre aki con takes place in a world
where anthropomorphic soda cans do
battle to determine which type of drink
container is superior steel or aluminum
caught up in this perplexing soda war is
high-school student Kakeru a collector
of rare soda containers who is taken by
surprise when his can of melon soda
transforms into a beautiful human girl
the creatively named melon needs to be
regularly infused with carbon dioxide in
order to survive as a human and defeat
her competitors and kokoro is more than
willing to help not only would it be
difficult to give any real residence to
an ongoing battle between living soda
cans
but a key Khan's over-the-top depiction
of certain stereotypes just wouldn't fly
in Hollywood this one's gonna have to be
kept in the can thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]